como hago con buena energía hasta ahora
ya de la tarde voy a empezar con algunas
preguntas
cuántos de ustedes han puesto una vacuna
todos han mandado un mensaje de texto en
los últimos 10 minutos en la conferencia
entonces ustedes han hecho un viaje en
avión en la última semana
gran pensar que son estas preguntas tan
básicas nuevas
ustedes sabían en 1796
edward jenner
inventó la vacuna de la viruela la
primera vacuna que se inventó
1900 la expectativa de vida era de 29
años
muchos de los que estamos aquí no
existiríamos
hoy la expectativa de vida es de 75 años
poco tiempo un aumento de 46 años en
américa latina estamos por encima del
promedio mundial
en 1800
cumplir a baby
inventó o tuvo la idea de generar luz
con un filamento
buena idea no pero cuesta en 1880
lo tomas edinson
en un sistema de distribución con esa
electricidad y trajo un poco a cada
hogar
se imaginan que sería hoy del internet
sería hoy de las comunicaciones sería
hoy de nuestras vidas en la luz
en el primer prototipo de avión
hablaba como a 30 metros
hoy o los que hemos montado en un avión
hemos estado a más de 10.000 metros de
altura en una velocidad de más de 800
kilómetros por hora
en una caja metálica
nos está aislando de una temperatura de
menos 42 grados
la humanidad de hecho cosas
extraordinarias
nosotros a veces se nos olvidan
la idea que les quiero compartir hoy
aquí
qué
muchos de ustedes muchos de nosotros
cuando nos hablan de tecnología pensamos
en el celular en un dispositivo en la
internet en una persona aburrida detrás
de un computador haciendo código
la tecnología hace parte de la vida de
cada uno de nosotros
si ustedes ven generan una línea de
tiempo
usa estos grandes cambios todas estas
grandes disrupciones todos estos grandes
momentos lo único que han generado
es una evolución mejoramiento en la
calidad de vida de los seres humanos la
idea real que quiero decirles y que
quiero transmitirles hoy
es la tecnología no es la solución la
tecnología no es el dispositivo
tecnología ha sido sólo un medio
al constante la real constante en esta
evolución así dos seres humanos
personas que han desarrollado la
tecnología
tecnología para ayudar a otras personas
se dan cuenta cada uno de los ejemplos
ha sido un ser humano un soñador quiso
mejorar la calidad de vida
en la humanidad
todos los grandes cambios todas las
grandes instrucciones siempre han
surgido de una minoría
una persona que quiere que se atreve
busca
entonces cuando hablamos de este cambio
hoy nos enfrentamos a nuevos retos a
nuevas tecnologías verdad hablamos de
inteligencia artificial de robótica de
internet de las cosas
en las posibilidades que podemos obtener
a través de estas tecnologías
cuando yo les digo tecnología todos
nosotros nos imaginamos robots no nos
imaginamos los revol los robots se van a
tomar el mundo
y van a acabar con la humanidad
así nos han vendido el futuro
piensan de eso
verdad
es que
e inteligencia artificial e internet de
las cosas lo único que van a hacer son
potencializar las posibilidades que
tenemos como seres humanos para generar
mejor calidad de vida pero la decisión
está en cada un
de nosotros
hablamos de inteligencia artificial y me
encanta esta referencia
kylie que tiene un libro muy interesante
de hecho que se llama inteligencia
artificial las superpotencias de la
inteligencia artificial china y silicon
valley
lo que quiero que vean aquí no es un
diagrama no traten de entender realmente
las posibilidades que hay con con estas
nuevas tecnologías lo interesante es que
una persona que ha estado muchísimos
años
hablando trabajando en tecnología
fue el director de microsoft research
que fue director de google
en china
de que el 47% de los trabajos que hoy
conocemos se van a perder
van a existir
lo que realmente
importa en ese proceso de transformación
hay una diferenciación única de los
seres humanos versus esas tecnologías
tecnologías nos van a sumar nos van a
ayudar nos van a potencializar cualquier
cosa que hagamos pero el ser humano
tiene una capacidad única
la ciudad de la compasión
es algo que ninguna tecnología
bueno el mundo futuro es desconocido
es algo que nada más va a poder
desarrollar
capacidad de la com
entonces va a perderse el 47% de los
trabajos
van a evolucionar y van a generarse
nuevos en donde la compasión es esa
característica que nos distingue que nos
hace únicos como seres humanos a tener
la relevancia
todo este camino de cambio y de
innovación perdonen es todo este camino
de cambio hay un proceso muy importante
si ya estamos de acuerdos si ya estamos
de acuerdo todos
el tema aquí es el ser humano en el
centro de todo
constante
se conoce como innovación
desarrollar la idea de innovación es muy
difícil si yo les digo
es innovación es muy difícil realmente
entender qué es la innovación
y se los voy a mostrar con un ejemplo
de género esta idea auto pp se llama
surgió nueva york
con el objetivo único de mejorar y
transformar la forma en la que nos
movemos
productos sin duda muy innovador una
gran idea verdad que fue desarrollada
en un laboratorio de personas que
estaban pensando en la forma de poner un
producto en el mercado
mayo
el auto peto se vendió muy bien
gente de un contexto no se entendió la
necesidad
la problemática del mundo real hoy un
siglo después los descubrirse están por
todo el mundo como una solución a
problemas de movilidad
nos entendemos en este proceso de
pensamiento en donde las personas somos
el centro de las decisiones que tomamos
tenemos que entender que todo lo que
hacemos tiene que tener la solución a un
objetivo de un mundo real
y en este ejemplo de movilidad
más que a través de él les voy a llevar
por tres conceptos claves a nivel de
innovación
y yo les digo
tenemos un problema grave de movilidad
en qué soluciones ustedes se empiezan a
pensar
muchos me dicen muchos me dicen bueno
los autos voladores antes de ustedes se
vieron los supersónicos
que pintaba en un 2.062 en el futuro en
donde los autos volaban vuelan
sigue siendo una constante en los
supersónicos cuando los autos vuelan
tráfico aéreo
están estancados todo el tiempo en el
aire millones y millones de autos
voladores
grandiosa tecnología pero resuelve el
problema real
nos lo dicen
los vehículos autónomos
van a generar 4000 gigas de información
todo el tiempo que van a estar
conectados con mi refrigerador y con el
supermercado y que van a saber antes que
yo que me falta la leche antes de que
llegue a casa y ya cuando llegue va a
estar la leche en mi red
y autos autónomos que son una gran
solución tecnológica pero
qué sirve tener autos autónomos si
nuestras calles están llenas de baches
la solución tecnológica que no resuelve
el problema
entonces
encontrar el problema correcto
ese es realmente la parte difícil
hablamos de innovación
hablamos de poder generar cambios
mejor en la calidad
le den una solución a una problemática
real pero encontrar ese problema es la
parte más difícil de toda la ecuación
les hablo de movilidad el 70 por ciento
y
van a ser urbanas el 70 del mundo va a
ser urbano qué significa eso 3 millones
de personas se mueven todos los días a
vivir en las grandes ciudades
eso genera
contaminación y un montón de problemas
una gran cantidad de problemas alrededor
de cómo vamos a vivir en esas ciudades
también habilita a otras cosas
maravillosas como comunicación
conectividad pero va a generar a nivel
de ciudad grandes problemas
porque el 30% de las emisiones que
generamos hoy
como por los autos literalmente estamos
quemando nuestro planeta
más gente se viene a vivir a las
ciudades y más personas van a tener un
coche que hoy el promedio de utilización
es de 1.1 personas por coche vamos solos
en nuestro coche lo utilizamos sólo el 4
el 5 por ciento del tiempo imagínense en
las ciudades
tres millones de personas cada día
llegando y comprando más coches
cientos 27 horas pasamos en el año
conduciendo
y todo esto se los cuento
que se necesitan 40 trillones de dólares
en infraestructura en los próximos 20
años
para abastecer estos cambios y este
crecimiento a nivel de población en las
grandes ciudades
no estamos viendo que nadie está
invirtiendo esa cantidad en arreglar ese
problema
entonces quién va a solucionar el
nosotros mismos les quiero contar
rápidamente el caso de weiss
y no para que conozcan solo el caso de
weiss sino porque esto puede y aplica
para todo lo que se puedan imaginar
voy siempre siente la vida en dos calles
dos personas estancadas en el tráfico
que se dieron cuenta en la información
cuando iban de un lugar a otro no
actualizado en tiempo real
entonces agarraron al elemento más
importante las mismas personas dijeron
vamos a poner a que estas personas sean
las que estén generando la información
todo el tiempo de lo que está pasando en
las calles
la solución más fácil hubiera sido poner
sensores en todas las esquinas
imagínense el costo de eso pero no las
personas empezaron a generar y generar
información ya crecer de dos a cuatro a
diez doscientas hacer las playas los
bloques las ciudades y hoy son más de
110 millones de personas en el mundo con
un objetivo en conjunto esto es lo que
se llama innovación social generar una
idea que ayude a una comunidad a llegar
de un punto a un punto b de una forma
rápida
pero no sólo eso esa idea siguió
creciendo y creciendo y hoy toda esta
información se comparte de manera
bidireccional con los gobiernos para
tomar decisiones de infraestructura y de
movilidad en las ciudades esta idea que
comenzó como innovación social se
convirtió en una innovación
transformacional innovación
transformacional es eso que puedes
construir para generar el cambio en la
forma en la que vivimos
y hoy la solución no son autos voladores
que no son autos autónomos es que cada
persona tome
esta decisión de compartir su coche y 60
personas que se ven así yendo todos los
días de su casa de trabajo
vean así
liber en las calles del tráfico
eso es lo que nace de los seres humanos
lo que pueden hacer de los seres humanos
y este ejemplo se los doy
por qué
el futuro inteligente
no es acerca de más tecnología
el futuro inteligente requiere humanidad
quiere que nosotros los que estamos aquí
sentados
cada una de las personas que está aquí
me la decisión y visualiza qué es lo que
quiere de su futuro
en torno a eso genere acciones hoy ya en
este momento para llegar ahí
muchas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]